überlebende ein buch das jetzt verfilmt
wurde
manchmal hat man schon das gefühl haben
was mir passiert das was sollen wir
jetzt noch passieren
man kann es nur annehmen man ganz nur
akzeptieren man kann es nicht ändern
dieses gefühl keine angst vorm tod zu
haben nutzt das fand ich sehr beruhigend
das gibt mir heute die die kraft zu
wissen ja also ich habe wirklich keine
angst davor
erkenntnisse die heike durchaus dem
grauenhaften verbrechen von vor drei
jahren gezogen hat
fast 18 jahre lang war sie mit ihm
zusammen stefan ramin
er wurde auf der insel nuku hiva
kaltblütig ermordet
an ihrem trauma hat ipad noch immer zu
tragen die 40 jährige lebt heute in
würzburg ihre heimatstadt hat schritt
für schritt wieder fuß im alltag gefasst
zurückgefunden in ein modernes urbanes
leben und doch die vergangenheit holt
sie immer wieder ein
auch in alpträumen die hatte ich am
anfang also sehr viel und sehr verstärkt
weil ich mich entschieden habe können
medikamente zu nehmen
ich überlege gerade war nicht das letzte
mal ein albtraum hat das war tatsächlich
auch verweilen auf der inselkette hawaii
die nuku hiva sehr ähnlich sieht hat das
zdf durch geschichte jetzt verfilmt
2008 bricht die marketingfachfrau mit
ihrer großen liebe zu einer
weltumsegelung auf fast vier jahre lang
ist das paar unterwegs
der traum ein leben auf dem meer im
einklang mit der natur
sie nennen es blaue wasser leben
paradies gelandet
doch das paradies wird zur hölle
wir haben so viele wilde ziegen enten
gesehen wir haben uns gefragt und ich
gerne werden
am 9 oktober 2011 geht stefan ramin mit
dem einheimischen ariane haiti auf
ziegen jagd
zurück konnte nicht
na dann
mariano lockt teig in den dschungel
fesselt sie belästigte sie sexuell wirkt
sie bekommen und habe wirklich gedacht
okay jetzt sterbe ich hier mitten im
wald mutterseelenalleine und ich war
überrascht dass ich ruhig war und dass
ich eigentlich gedacht habe dann ist es
so doch heike kann sich befreien
sie flieht
rettet sich mit letzter kraft auf das
boot von freunden das ebenfalls in der
bucht vor anker liegt
drei tage später wird eine feuerstelle
entdeckt mit verkohlten menschlichen
überresten die dna und zahnanalyse
bestätigt die schlimmsten befürchtungen
ihr buch war ein tiefes bedürfnis sich
der vergangenheit zu stellen
meine art wasser haben mich immer damit
zu konfrontieren
aber ich habe halt immer eine gute
balance gefunden immer geguckt wie weit
kann ich gehen was kann ich meiner seele
zumuten und und was das einfach zu viel
das unfassbare niederschreiben für heike
durch eine art therapie dazu gehört auch
die schönen momente ihre reise in
erinnerung zu behalten
ebenso der fehlen bei dessen entstehung
sie dabei war
während die diesen film gedreht haben
habe ich einfach selber eigene bilder
gesehen also ich habe meine bilder
gesehen meine geschichte und da wurde
ich natürlich sehr stark wieder
zurückgeworfen was tatsächlich passiert
ist auf der anderen seite kamen dann
irgendwie keine ahnung der typen der
sonnencreme hat gemeint ich werde ich
mal eine sonne brennt also mann wurde
dann sozusagen wieder in die jetzt
katapultiert
das war immer so ein sondern hin und her
verarbeitungstechnik spaness schon ihre
ebenfalls eine extremsituation die
gegenüberstellung ein halbes jahr nach
der grausamen tat ein weiterer
erfolgloser versucht den fall zu
rekonstruieren
ewige ungewissheit
ist das das zur morgens dem
das schlimmste ist glaube ich dass
stefan tod ist ja alles andere kann man
verarbeiten dran arbeiten verkraften
aber dass stephen tot ist und des
kaufens daniel stephan rahmens mörder
wurde letzten mai zu 28 jahren gefängnis
verurteilt